With my diagnosis, is it safe for me to use collagen? I struggle with dry skin air and brittle nails
Well, I do ox also have a blog post on collagen and that
Though there's conflicting research with collagen and cancer
The there there was research back about 20 years ago say that collagen can be beneficial with cancer
And then there's newer research that says collagen can actually drive cancer
So when you have conflicting research with something like that that
There may be you know that you can kind of
Understand that there is not a lot of bias in those in those articles
You have to think that I typically fall on the side of I wouldn't use collagen if my cancer was really active
So if my cancer was not active and I was in a state of relative remission
I don't think there's anything wrong with using collagen now don't
confuse
Collagen with colostrum
So kind of similar
Words there, but they're different so collagen and colostrum are different
Now it used to be very difficult to get colostrum. Now there's many sources of colostrum out there
You don't want to use colostrum with cancer
But collagen with cancer if you're in a state of remission or relative remission
I don't think there's anything wrong with doing some collagen to help with your hair and nails